avec nous maintenant Mona Fortier
président du Conseil du Trésor qu'on
retrouve à Ottawa madame Fortier bonsoir
oui la grève dure depuis huit jours
maintenant on entend cette deuxième
semaine puis on sent pas que la
motivation des syndiqués fléchies en ce
moment les manifestations prennent de
l'ampleur il y a des services fédéraux
qui sont ralentis est-ce que la
situation est en train de déraper
moi je vous dirais à ce moment-ci que
j'ai fait un signal aujourd'hui que
j'étais frustrée du fait que on a une
bonne offre sur la table neuf qui est
raisonnable une offre qui est abordable
et qui est juste pour les employés
évidemment pour les contribuables donc
je souhaite qu'on puisse continuer les
conversations évidemment difficiles mais
importantes et j'invite l'alliance à
nous faire une proposition qui nous
permettrait que ce soit abordable et
raisonnable mais là aidez-nous à
comprendre parce que vous offrez 9% sur
trois ans le syndicat demande 13,5% sur
trois ans il me semble qu'entre neuf et
13 et 13 et demi pour ça là le chemin
est quand même pas très très long
pourquoi pourquoi on n'arrive pas à une
entente dans l'intérêt des Canadiens de
l'économie canadienne oui vous avez
complètement raison nous on se sert et
ils sont très au courant l'alliance on
se sert d'un tiers partie une
recommandation qui a été fait par le
commission d'intérêt public qui disait
qu'à 9 % c'est une entente qui est
raisonnable et qui reflète une
augmentation importante pour les
fonctionnaires je voulais vous donner
juste si vous me permettez pour que vos
les gens qui écoutent l'augmentation
salariale moyenne pour chaque
fonctionnaire qui aura un salaire autour
de 67000 dollars cela voudrait dire
d'une augmentation bon de 9% sur trois
ans serait d'environ 6250 parfois on me
demande un chiffre donc je voulais juste
vous le partager pour que vous sachiez
aller à 10 ou à 11%, est-ce que est-ce
qu'il y a pas un chemin entre les deux
ça a l'air facile vu d'ici là mais
on regarde ça comme canadien comme
citoyen comme contribuable comment ça se
fait que vous êtes pas capable d'arriver
à une entente on est rendu à huit jours
de grève alors il faudrait que
l'alliance diminue un peu plus même plus
que Christ qui ont fait à date pour
qu'on puisse se retrouver des
conversations qui vont avoir un résultat
qu'on va pouvoir arriver à une entente
mais j'en ai pas beaucoup qui me reste
alors on est présentement à 9 % on peut
se trouver évidemment des façons
créatives pour pouvoir donner un peu
plus mais à ce moment-ci va falloir que
l'alliance fasse une une étape
importante pour qu'on puisse continuer
ses conversations là sur une question
pour monter un petit peu plus donc à 10
ou 11 % c'est peut-être pas en termes de
pourcentage pour être honnête j'ai
peut-être d'autres flexibilité qui vont
permettre de de démontrer que nous avons
un salaire qui permet au fonctionnaires
que ce soit raisonnable puis en même
temps que ce soit pardon que ce soit
juste et que ce soit raisonnable pour
les contribuables l'Alliance de la
fonction publique a reproché au Conseil
du Trésor d'avoir quitté la table un peu
tôt hier comment on arrive à une entente
si on négocie pas de façon intensive on
commencera pas à regarder l'heure ils
sont restés très tard hier soir à
discuter même avec le médiateur alors je
sais pas qui regarde qui mais on est à
la table à tous les jours on reste très
tard l'équipe de négociation elle est là
depuis plus de trois semaines je
voudrais quand même rappeler parce qu'il
y en a plusieurs qui me posaient la
question aujourd'hui pourquoi ça a pris
autant de temps il faut juste se
rappeler que l'année dernière appareil
date environ nous avions déposé notre
première offre monétaire et cette offre
a été refusée sur le champ par
l'Alliance et on nous a quitté la table
on nous a boudé pour un bon bout de
temps jusqu'à temps qu'on s'entende de
retourner en médiation le 2 avril
dernier donc vous savez là on a depuis
trois semaines et un jour si je me
trompe pas été à la table tous les jours
puis on est passé parce que je veux
quand même donner un sens qui a eu du
progrès alors on est passé de 570
d'amandes qui avaient été tablés au
début du processus et là avec la lettre
ouverte que j'ai mis en ligne deux jours
passés on démontre que beaucoup de
progrès il nous reste quelques éléments
dont les salaires qu'il faut discuter
alors vous avez parlé de frustration
vous dites que vous êtes frustré de la
situation en ce moment vous exprimez ça
publiquement vous nous donnez une
entrevue est-ce que ça veut dire que
votre patience arrive au bout de sa
limite et qu'une loi spéciale
est prête
non je vous dis pas que ma patience a
pas une certaine limite je vais toujours
avoir de la patience moi je pense
vraiment que la meilleure façon qu'on
peut atteindre à une entente c'est à la
table de négociation tout en respectant
évidemment le conflit de travail les
travailleurs ont droit de faire la grève
mais pour moi la meilleure est-ce que
vous avez un document de loi spéciale
prêt si on devait aller là non c'est pas
du tout à l'étude au Conseil du Trésor
non présentement on met tous nos
énergies nos efforts à la table de
négocier à son parce que c'est cette
endroit qui va nous permettre d'avoir la
meilleure est-ce que le premier ministre
du Canada Justin Trudeau devrait
s'impliquer directement dans les
négociations je l'informe à tous les
jours et
il m'a encore aujourd'hui demander si
tout se passait comme nous voulions il a
répondu en chambre également on
travaille en équipe et puis je continue
ma responsabilité
c'est d'avoir une entente qui va être
juste pour les employés et également qui
va être
équitable et raisonnable pour les
Québécois québécois le Premier ministre
va s'impliquer dans le dossier
directement mais il m'a déjà donné un
mandat donc j'ai le mandat entre les
mains et je continue à travailler avec
l'équipe de négociations pour arriver à
un entente merci d'avoir été avec nous
ce soir merci beaucoup de m'avoir reçu
pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI
[Musique]